across a huge rural swathe of central
canada communities are shocked but on
high alert and frightened too as one of
the nation's largest manhunts continues
police have been drafted in from across
the country after the most extraordinary
series of attacks stabbings in multiple
locations no known motive and few clues
damien sanderson on the left is 31 and
miles sanderson is 30. the police have
not said if the two are related but they
are considered to be dangerous and
should not be approached
it's believed they stole this vehicle
from the home of one of the victims a
black nissan with local number plates
it was before dawn just after 5 30 when
the police received the first 911
the unfolding horror was soon clear with
multiple calls from all over a wide area
air ambulances were in the air in
minutes
we've got a fresh set of investigators
and shifts coming in today
that will take over this investigation
and we will not stop this investigation
until we have those two safely in
custody the province of saskatchewan
lies in the center of canada the largely
indigenous communities targeted are
small and isolated from each other the
police have identified 13 crime scenes
at several locations in james smith cree
nation and the smaller village of weldon
half an hour drive west
the last sighting of the suspects was in
regina three and a half hours away six
hours after the first attack police are
now beyond those critical first few
hours and so the call for public
vigilance is spreading further and
further
any community this is a devastating
tragedy but a community that small where
everyone knows everyone
i can only imagine the pain and the
horror that not only the chief is going
through but but the whole community and
our hearts really do go out to them
among the victims lana head a mother and
a grandmother
police have suggested that some of the
victims appear to have been specifically
targeted other attacks were random but
they do not yet have a motive a clear
understanding of how or why this
happened mark stone sky news